oh my god guys stop flirting i need to
okay i'm sorry sorry
i'll keep right now
[Music]
hi my name is abeeda from geek culture
and singapore um right here we also have
one of my colleagues in zaki but he's a
little shy
um how are you louie
yeah i'm good i'm good zack he's just
hiding okay i'm very good hi amira hi
ducky hey ludy how you doing
yes i'm excellent thank you yeah you
look great man
[Music]
i like your icon man your eye is very
pretty thank you so much i'm very shy
today
oh my god guys stop writing i need to
okay i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'll keep right now
now this is a question that i've been
wanting to ask from when i first saw
your tweet louie you want to describe
moral combat as the best r-rated comedy
of all time so can you like elaborate on
that
yeah actually i think of it as a
bromantic comedy because i think that's
what's going on between um the shaolin
bros
you know they stick by each other and
uh they literally um support each other
in their life because i think their
common background is that they're both
um lacking something liu kang comes from
a very traumatic uh orphan background
and
kung lao i think he he's got
he never feels like he's good enough so
he has to act out so and then added by
the comedy that um
that kano injects into the movie
cute
real cute
let's see drop down again
i want to frame it as that i want to i
want people to know that this isn't just
about blood but it's also about heart
processing because honestly when i saw
that tweet i was expecting something
like really spicy to happen between like
you kang and kung lao
i was like you guys like cousins like i
feel so wrong
that is a little wrong isn't it
yeah but i'm glad like you guys deserve
to be you guys are like brothers from
another mother anyway so
yeah we me and max um the person who
plays kung lao we actually have known
each other for 10 years uh we met on an
action movie set um
in china about 10 years ago and he's
been on you know jackie chan's team for
for that long yeah we've been talking
ever since
because speaking of action films i know
that you are not new to like combat
fighting you know there are a bunch of
scenes that you did that zacky and i
reset beside each other like holy [ __ ]
like you did that like
was it like a walk in the park for you
when you were training or were there
some learning curves like how was
training like
no it's like a walk in hell and some of
these locations are really like
uh they were out of this world we filmed
in uh the middle of australia and you
know the the the stunt team was so good
in preparing us for what we need to do
but um when we get on location sometimes
it's just really tough it's like
um
you know thousands of miles from the
nearest city uh in the middle of the
night in a rock quarry in the desert
where it's so cold and we had to set
fire to the place and do all this stuff
and
shoot through the night and
yeah it's really draining it's really
grueling on the body i'm glad i have a
really healthy
uh i'm vegan so i'm plan powered my
body's 100
that's great wow maybe i should go vegan
can you explain to me like the whole
bicycle kick move like how did you do
that
uh okay so we tested a lot of different
styles for the bicycle kick move because
in the video game he just goes and it
defies the laws of physics
right so we wanted something that
actually looked like it might be real um
so we practiced a lot of different
iterations and then just in post they
put it together and made it come true
so it doesn't look like it's just a
cartoonish video game move
and you can actually pull it off
and that's also just a huge shout out to
kyle gardner and chan who are the stunt
coordinators on this film i've worked
with them on aquaman and also on marco
polo so i know what they can do and they
did it it wasn't an easy job but they
got it done
were you excited to do it are you a big
fan of the games
i i am a huge fan i'm a i'm like the
best friend
of the game and it was a best friend to
me it was a long time companion of me
when i was just a lonely little kid
traveling from place to place
um
yeah so it was really gratifying to be
able to do this
okay so we're going to test how big of a
fan you are we actually prepare it like
a little game for you
okay so you kind of just have to guess
the character based on a really obscure
image okay
okay
this is the hardest game i've done so
far
i think that's kung lao
you are totally right how did you know
that like the the the van race
he's my bro he's my romantic partner
that's right that's the answer i was
looking for
oh my god
um
it's just a butt
this is very distracting
um
does molina have a whip
who has a whip i'm gonna say that's a
jade
oh katana
oh man i should being liu kang i should
know that butt anywhere
can't believe it
sub-zero
yeah
i would be surprised if you didn't get
this one
malina
wait
this is the tricky one
no that's not molina
uh
oh gosh i know who it is i forget his
name he's got four arms
this
his name starts with the letter b
baraka
yup yeah
definitely
you guys are tough
you guys are so tough this is supposed
to test how much of a fan you are but
you're doing so great
the last one
okay
one more time one more chance this is
rated
is it that is a rating though
takes that
that um that jewel
in the story so i was wondering
you guys you guys yeah the tricky one
all right cool
that was difficult you guys are making
life very difficult for me
oh i'm sorry but you did so well i i
think you did fairly well
but that's gonna be mad though
okay i think that's all we have for
today but thank you so much for
answering my questions and for playing
this game with us uh i hope you had fun
i did that was brilliant thanks for your
time thank you
have a good one happy easter
oh happy easter thank you